what's up everybody I'm Chris Sims and
these are my favorite football movies I
got five of them and here we go number
one no doubt about it in my mind
Remember the Titans with Denzel
Washington I mean come on the cultural
background of the story you know black
high school white school coming together
and really kind of very cohesively going
on to dominate and then win the state
championship that's number one for me
forever the night of taters
number two we Rudy Rudy I mean the
ultimate like never give up just keep
fighting keep chasing your dreams and
then he gets on the field at the great
ending and it's Notre Dame football come
on I got to get that number two okay
number three The Blind Side yes you
remember Sandra Bullock okay yeah that's
pretty awesome story a family you know
adopting adopting a guy bringing him
into his family and then he goes on to
play in the NFL that whole story I mean
that's just a feel-good awesome story
nice human humanity story all that I
don't even know what I'm saying but it's
a good movie you guys know what I mean I
said you could thank you later
it's later birth number four I'm going
way back with this one okay I think it's
the 70s died money into the late sixties
I'm pretty sure it's the 70s though The
Longest Yard with Burt Reynolds I don't
want the Adam Sandler one I want the
Burt Reynolds one when they're in jail
and they take on the guards and the guy
hits the guy and goes I think I broke
his neck okay there's another word in
between there as you can imagine come to
slide again there's a stub now let's do
it and then number five okay this is a
doozy
I don't know if a lot of people remember
this but wild cats of Goldie Hawn when
she becomes the head football coach
Wesley Snipes is on the team Woody
Harrelson's the quarterback that gets
benched I mean Bubba Gump the guy that's
Bubba Gump in the movie I can't remember
his real name but I'm just gonna call
him Bubba Gump right now Wildcats I'm
telling you go back and see that one
that is a classic for me there's my top
five hopefully everybody enjoyed it
[Music]